tandis que nous on se trouve sur banner
est toujours debout mais commencer par
milliards 2 millions nouvelle partie en
fait c'est un jeu de plateforme qui va
potentiellement nous faire rager dans la
rage vous savez bien c'est bien d'abord
ça aussi ben il vit dans un monde nul
un jour il a trouvé aide le premier mort
vivants ils sont devenus amis cet homme
a entendu parler de il les a divisés on
les utilisait pour créer le meilleur jeu
télévisé du monde
ok très bien donc on doit retrouver
notre pote l'humain allez on est chaud
c'est quoi des canettes d'accord voilà
donc à chaque niveau on va devoir
recruter des conserves comme ça allait
on voit la difficulté s'il vous plaît ok
on y va à aider la moquée des de
l'âme qui nous coupe on s'en bat les
steaks parce qu'on a remis au nom j'ai
fait une roulade style et quel talent
merci checkpoint ça par contre ça fait
plaisir à bassa c'est ce qui fait de
balai mais ben je vraiment à part
attendez je sais je sais mon point
faible en fait c'est que maaf pas de
temps d'arrêt real a marqué un petit on
arrive doit bien se passer
relève toi attend bec je suis bloqué là
mais je crois que j'ai un bug servons
nous avons eu du mal à analyser la
situation en fait aulas le petit temps
d'arrêt nous a mis bien je vous l'avais
dit d'y aller ce connard de caméraman à
gauche bâtard va te vois ma tête je suis
à tp oui oui oui
on attend trop bien là ah non voilà très
simple ça c'était simple ouais ça fait
mal
le châtiment ouais bah non bah non pas
du tout paf sans jambes aux bras
cegedim a du coup pas sous la lame qui
tue à faire ah c'est pas mal ça oui allô
fini comme ça c'est plus un pub je dire
j'aimerais qu'il n'ait jamais de jambes
oh non non la lame était plus basse ou
sata voit ses parts à ses parts à ses
parts à part regarder ça au fait que
c'est pas le vrai ah si c'est le vrai
mais les gens regardent cei à aucun
moment ils se disent à tomber c'est
abusé store franck et dans une cage
merci c'est grâce à vous c'est un
travail d'équipé lacombe a effectué un
ok troisième levett voudrais pas les
boules vous n'aurez pas oui à celle de
gauche arriverait avant celle de droite
au ska hockey ou bah non
oh là là oh là là le manque de génie les
génies ont dit oreca oui la difficulté
s'il vous plaît c'est là j'en vois pas
trop ok c'est petit perth pt6a ok j'ai
compris
bamba k
alé lô au bâlois montminy eu ma d'accord
et malté que les distances jmal
qu'éculée un trou et ce n'est pas juste
avec une tête on est carrément
invincible attendait mais c'est trop
tchité pour de vrais fous rires ah voilà
voilà où je suivais des pages arrachées
en deuil je lance non non non la page
faire ça bloque voilà je peux te le dire
là il évoqua chez-nous franco comme
james franco aux débats n'ont semblé ma
blague se plaît là mm bed ed ed sheeran
ok peut-être qu'une jambe c'est chaud
mais ça passe au nom
pourquoi pourquoi ouais c'est voir sa
part sain passe nickel tout effet été
prévu en raccourci raccourci gëstu à
faire c'est ça de jouer souvent jeu
vidéo on voit les petits raccourcis
comme ça du fdp
eh bien non je suis même un petit peu
hautain souhait ce que je veux dire elle
ce parti pourrait dans le canon c'est
tous encore une fois le travail équipe a
régné à renier allez on continue c'est
pas haut et catherine géant ok ça va
être aux attaques hors nickel et relents
nous défoncer ok j'ai compris on doit
monter à hauteur plus quand les canons
pour aller se battre en vain ok ce parti
c'est par là et c'est parti alors on
ajustera les ces de main et puis
on va esquivé syfy vod qui peut nous en
fait nous d'en faire un voilà comme ça
on n'a pas le choix
le pape a blagué papa je tourne en fait
quand je vais sur sa main auj
holà aux lattois c'est sérieux je sois
tranquille laissera tranquille ok
ok en laisse qui dit on est bon mais bon
on peut y aller messi n'a toujours pas
compris qu'on était à l'étagé beaucoup
trop con bon et l'a compris en fait
allez allez le canon le 4 oct aip du
canon et tout ménage pour l abattoir
d'un truc et
cheikh échec en fait foi les la droite
je suis débile j'avais pas vu regardes
et tu te faire ça on a le canon dans le
canot et la fois les housses achoppement
pas à dans sa bouche peut-être non non
la regarder voilà plus tard auquel il
est à toi je souhaitais à coup de bluff
en a du coup il ya perdu une vie vous
avez vu il va aller deux fois plus vite
en haut ou à taiwo vit tout gérer ton
spectacle est super drôle tu avec
celle au cloud
hop là ça passe à plat ça passe mais non
non mon gars mais lutteront mais c'est
une blague quoi allez on y va on y va on
y va on y va on y va
oh attends je suis tout tendues la save
à l'arrivée passe pas pour autant le
canot rabaska tout d'abord du coup à
poils et à l'autre canon qui en face du
coup on a deux fois plus de chemin à
faire parce qu'on est con mais non allez
mettons donc en âge vers nous te plaît
ttc bâtard n'a pas reconduit m a
déchaîné au monde j'ai été chez nous
ohlala mon gardien si on pas cet endroit
servira qu une fois qu'ils ne tentent de
ouf on est passé what you're gonna do
and coming
on sait bien la mode est enfin attention
dès qu'il va lever sa main en plus c'est
juste à côté attendez on va ton petit
rebond mais mais qui me fait des chromos
il fait des combats une place au tpiy
mais un coup de la tranche de la main
à tort il faut carrément qui se
détend d'un coup un raid
il m'a dit non mais mec
oh là là mais mec c'est dur
j'aime tant may hamm temps là qu'ils
fassent ça super vite avec ça ma
on est presque envie de pleurer j'en ai
chialé au jour na'vi c'est une blague
mais non mais c'est une sorte de blague
pas une bonne blague complète une petite
boutade hockey speed rose se videra on
n'a pas le temps
pourquoi toujours vers l'arrière parce
que c'est plus dur et il le sait aller
alors la muga maintenant au wat uguale
attounsiya et lâche échec pour monter un
tel accueil neji fleurs qu'il est mort
on and à 10 sur 12 mois ça passe et
voilà il nous faut il encore entre les
doigts ou et quel travail des kits je
suis tout ému je suis ému je vous fais
de gros bisous et félicitations
elle d'aller faire du sport cette
musique nord à aa
oui mais j'en suis à peu près sûr belle
ml et je peux vous dire qu'il aurait une
seconde vidéo c'est sûr et certain j'ai
adoré ce jeu mais ça me regarde et
n'hésitez-pas mendoça vous appeler pour
se tourner très vite et dans une
prochaine je vous fais plein de bisous
on n'oublie pas le travail d'équipé
attention quand il viendra du monde
pizza
à